What's my boa Benvenuti su tifest Sword
che in italiano significa
la spada profonda cioè io posso Ah ok Io
col mouse con la spada va bene No come
cacchio funziona solo allora vsd per
muoversi ok e la spada con il tasto
sinistro ok È una cosa molto ambigua va
bene eh il mouse Ah ok La spada mi
solleva anche va bene Long the dragon
vive davanti drago che si chiama drago
il lungo va bene Hello Io ho la spada
lunga dai Porca [ __ ] Buongiorno dai il
tuo miglior affondo affonda nel suo
cuore va bene Sì ma la spada è piccola
Cioè nel senso
ragazzi prima di darmi fuoco ha detto ma
è già entrato
io non posso fare questo video ti ho
portato indietro Ho fatto la tua strada
più lunga più lunga perché questo
Ragazzi è un po' il Dark Souls che non
abbiamo chiesto ma che ci meritiamo
effettivamente Mettila più in fondo
questa volta ma va bene La caverna
sembra molto più profonda di prima ok
Sono veramente Premiere per riparare
checkpoint Ah ok perché questi sono
Check Point Ah quindi adesso la
difficoltà è anche arrivare al Drago Va
bene non ci passo c'ho la spada troppo
grossa eh non è mai una cosa che ho
detto nella mia vita aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
Eccoci No no come cazzo ci fa non ci
posso di qua Oddio
non come come faccio a passati Scusatemi
che qua sto avendo problemi non ci passo
non ci passo aspetta no
Oddio non so come ho fatto va bene Salve
signor signora draghessa credo che sia
una traghessa a giudicare dal dagli
occhi
Sei qua per riprovarci Let's go
di tutto questo c'è il gatto che sta
osservando Vabbè
Eh mi fa il solletico Ma dai ma dai ma
cosa sto leggendo allungato la tua spada
ancora un pochettino vabbè Stai attento
al peso Ragazzi ma che
Chi ha pensato a sto gioco a che cazzo a
che cosa aveva in testa Vi prego no
voglio sapere ho bisogno di sapere
questa cosa Scusatemi ok no ok ok
aspetta eh Porca vacca devo fare sto
giro Cioè è diventa è un mezzo Parkour
ragazzi è diventato un Parkour Cioè
veramente assurdo Aspetta eh
Yes calmo
Madonna ragazzi che cavaliere Number One
Let's go my balls Ciao tesoro Eh aspetta
che la spada è più lunga Aspetta che la
spada è più lunga Questa è la parte di
Shrek che non hanno fatto vedere quello
quando Ciuchino questa volta ho sentito
qualcosa Sì però mi dà il fuoco non mi
dare fuoco ogni volta mi sembra
esagerato sei quasi al limite
ragazzi Stiamo arrivando stiamo
raggiungendo il il treshuve più grande
sono veramente curioso di leggere il
dialogo che arriverà tra un po' Eh
perché adesso quello sarà importante che
non passa neanche dall'entrata stavolta
ogni volta ragazzi che gioca qualcosa mi
sento in qualche modo di dire che sono
arrivato al momento più alto della mia
carriera ma eh effettivamente questo lo
è cioè nel senso di che parliamo di cosa
parliamo
Addirittura mi fa fare tutto un giro
dall'altra parte che casino Ok let's go
Madonna che Pro Gamer manco Power Power
non ci gioca a sti giochi eh
Ciao
Allora tesoro e ho visto su Tinder che
mi hai risposto spada lunga che c'hai
Sarebbe bello sentire ogni tanto allora
aspetta un attimo
Oh molto profondo stavolta si è sorpreso
sorpresa stavolta Sei sorpreso Questa è
la spada d'oro Questa è la spada più
profonda cioè che l'ha detto lui eh non
l'ho detto Ha detto la spada più
profonda ha detto lui così profonda
ragazzi che cazzo succede speriamo che i
miei genitori non guardi non si vedono
Giampiero cosa stai montando Ormai tanto
è tutto un doppio senso
o Gesù aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
perfetto perfetto Madonna ragazzi
neanche la zuiander di mi sono bloccato
Ah ok neanche la sveglia di Dark Souls è
veramente così cioè proprio qua Stiamo
arrivando a livelli cioè stratosferici
altro che Praise the sun Praise the
dragon No vabbè non si vede Oddio Forse
sì che ne so Vabbè non diciamo cose
Oddio
Forse posso passare di qua stavolta
Aspetta Aspetta madonna
mi fa sempre mi fa sempre la paura anche
Ok No dai
tirati sopra bravissimo Ciao
Oddio no non sono arrivati Come faccio
qua Aspetta aiuto Come faccio a fare sta
roba No non mi dire che cosa di qua oh
santo di Dio mi sembra un po' mi sembra
mi sembra un po' un'esagerazione ragazzi
No vabbè aspetta Non ce la farò mai C'è
qualche problema di fondo qua
non mi fido non mi basta non mi basta
non mi basta c'è un medico che c'è un
pixel in meno Mi si incastra la gamba
perfettamente in questo pixel attenzione
proprio lui
come ci arrivo qua sopra aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta che questa non
l'avevo sbagliato Se cado Madonna è
finita disinstallo il gioco non che si è
installato perché sto gioco perché pesa
3 mega Però come faccio a passarla sopra
ci ho messo due ore
Ma no ti prego
non ci stiamo capendo oh una volta che
capisci come si fa ci metti un secondo
però è quello il fatto che così Bisogna
solo capire la dinamica poi è stato
facile qua Non lo so però
Madonna raga pazzesco non è vero che non
è vero che cado per favore
Madonna che casino Madonna porta
ho preso il checkpoint ho preso il
cervello Allora il checkpoint è già
un'ottima cosa Madonna ma l'hanno fatta
veramente difficile l'ultima parte c'è
veramente un disastro
ce l'ho fatta ok
Oddio sì è entrata Sì
a drago ci ho messo due ore per
prepararmi Ma ci sono con la mia spada
grossa
Oh aspetta un minuto attenzione che qua
arriviamo a dichiarazioni importanti
Aspetta un minuto
mi pesa troppo la spada attenzione gatto
Guarda questa eh
io non posso veramente Oh sacrosanto
Iddio
ok
Ma che cazzo giochiamo
ho salvato il gatto che ha appena detto
Sei venuto per me va bene tipes Sword il
gioco dell'anno probabilmente non saprei
come commentarlo signori ci rivediamo al
prossimo video lasciate un commento mi
piace anche ai vari Social che come io
sono stata in descrizione Se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]